[Music]
fortnite storyline is all over the place
and as soon as we understand a single
thread of it they add more law to
confuse us yet again today i collected
the best six theories about the
direction of fortnite storyline in an
attempt to predict the future so sit
your butt down for 10 minutes slap code
adamaru to support videos like this and
let's uncover what epic games is
planning in season 8.
okay a super quick recap since chapter
two began we've slowly had the lore of
the world handed to us which affected
the following seasons like dominoes
season two saw a top secret device built
to fight the storm which eventually
brought an agent from the real world
into the loop to prevent us from
escaping agent jones then went too far
and broke the very thing he was here to
protect the zero point by overusing a
shard from it to bring in new heroes to
defend it jonesy then defected at the
beginning of season six and went against
his superior to find a member of the
seven a group we know little about right
now we've seen three members before in
chapter one the visitor who attempted to
find the original zero point the
paradigm who we'll talk about very soon
and the scientist who demolished the
zero point in an attempt to break the
cycle it failed we still remain the
newest member of the seven is the
foundation and judging by his comments
he's been around the longest and is
their leader just as we were about to
get answers from the foundation he was
forced to steal himself in the zero
point to protect reality and agent
jonesy became lost in the loop and then
an alien race appeared and took the zero
point leaving the foundation somewhere
around here in a lot of water and that's
a very quick update i missed some things
like aquaman was around at some point
now and now on to our first theory the
past is the future
[Music]
one of the first things we all noticed
about the alien mothership was its
resemblance to the vault back in chapter
one the same style aperture opening and
metallic outer casing back then we
jumped into the vault which housed the
zero point we were all too preoccupied
with voting for the drum gun to make
twitch streamers cry we also missed lots
of other clues about the future we'll
leave those there for another theory
later in this video many people have
suggested that the mothership above us
will become the vault below us we know
the current mothership has the zero
point but how could the ship become the
ground beneath us
simply put the mother ship must crash on
the island fortnite leaker fort torrey
uncovered this sound file which confirms
this theory
one minor detail if we take down the
mother ship the crash landing is not
going to be pretty
a few billion tons of flaming debris
crashing into the island is bound to
cause some problems you'll have to be
creative but i trust you
sloan wants to crash the ship onto the
island and that's a big ass ship but
that doesn't make the past the future
well let's crack on remember the black
hole event that reset the timeline like
never before a whole new island to
discover but many places already existed
in the old world how could that be
possible well the key to all this is the
basic concept that everything is a loop
constantly restarting over and over and
over again now let's go back to johnsy's
actions in season six he used the portal
device to bring back the foundation not
only did this change the time frame of
the loop it literally brought back the
dawning of time the primal era before
technology before the zero point became
active theoretically by taking us back
in time it is now possible to shoot down
the mothership and over months and years
build on top of it as we all lose our
memories again and eventually the loop
catches up back to the future back to
the vault the past is the future what do
you think of that theory please write
each theory out of 10 in the comments
let's find out what's our favorite okay
another one theory two is the dc season
if you didn't know over the past few
months the batman zero point comic book
series has given us a bunch of lore to
help us build an image of the future if
you want to see each episode in detail
be sure to check out the series but
right now i'm gonna spoil the ending so
run away if you don't know how that ends
are they gone good batman and catwoman
are successful in escaping the loop and
returning to gotham but we then find out
it was all a ruse and the person behind
it is none other than sloane jonesy's
former boss and the person giving us
missions each week in the game right now
sloane has partnered with lex luthor and
the batman who laughs to find a safe way
in and out of the loop successfully the
last images of the story show us that
they made a new rift not in gotham this
time but in metropolis the home of
superman and as you already know clark
kent superman has made it into fortnite
remember earlier when sloane spoke about
a weapon to bring down the ship i always
thought it was the bomb we see in the i
o buildings and it very well could be
but what if superman is the weapon and
all the work sloan and lex luthor did
was to bring clark kent here to be the
puppet of the io the chap in charge of
all the creative story decisions in
fortnite aka the donald we call mustard
told us that superman will have a very
important role to play in the season and
i for one would love to see superman
single-handedly take down a mother ship
wouldn't you speaking of donald mustard
he has repeatedly found a way to include
a sculpture of wonder woman in his posts
including one at the rift tour event
this week it's been going on for so long
now that she must be on her way and
there's also a few new series of dc
fortnite comic books coming and judging
by the end of the zero point run we'll
be seeing the batman who laughs and lex
luthor in fortnite soon and remember the
joker poison ivy and another midas
snapshot are already here just waiting
to be relevant
i personally have no doubt a dc season
was slated but there was a great deal of
people who disliked the marvel season so
the dc season may be postponed how would
you feel about a dc season with sloane
and lex luthor teaming up theory 3
singularity is the alien queen
for this one we need to go all the way
back to the gaiju mecca fight in chapter
one season nine this is still my
favorite event by the way this was the
season that singularity appeared to us
and seemingly was responsible for
building the mech which eventually
stopped the monster i mean even the
sword that was used to skewer the
monster had singularity as the handle
she's definitely important to this and
then suddenly the mech just left flew
straight into space never to be seen
again but let's go back a little more
than that to the unvolting remember the
items on the table near the zero point
here we could find singularity's helmet
inside the bolt if we take a page out of
theory one and say the vault is an alien
craft this could mean singularity is
aboard the mothership this season
things get very interesting now recently
i've started thinking singularity has
very similar armor to the aliens and
then this bombshell hit me the final
variation to the suit they wear is
called singularity and wait there's more
back to the mustard donald has told us
the name of the alien invaders the last
reality and the closest synonym to the
phrase the last reality is singularity
that can't be a coincidence not only
that but donald also told us that
singularity is integral to the story and
that she has another name if you know my
channel you'll know that i've believed
for a long time that singularity is
paradigm a member of the seven who never
appeared in any cutscenes or law she
appeared one day and was gone the next
and she also has the exact same physique
as singularity could this be here to put
us off the scent or is she the queen and
leader of the last reality looking to
restore a singularity paradigm to the
loop the evidence is certainly there the
return of chapter one's pois in their
exact position without any reason the
worlds are realigning into one and now
we see the mother ship literally lifting
locations out of the ground and taking
them into the mothership at the event
this was taken even further with the
aliens scanning us for information about
the zero point and its power
i wouldn't be surprised to see
singularity as the leader of the alien
race i guess we wait and see theory 4
the return of agent jones
[Music]
at the beginning of season 6 agent jones
brought back the founding member of the
seven the foundation and it became
apparent they knew each other
i can get you to jenna
and the sisters i can get you all on but
then one lost their memory and the other
became a rock no pun intended fast
forward a season and the foundation is
free but as of yet he still hasn't been
found or given up his location
back to twitter we go as donald mustard
spoke about how much troy baker knows
about the fortnite storyline and for
those who don't know troy plays agent
jonesy in fortnite
he also plays joel in the last of us and
the spin-off second game about golf this
tells us either troy has recorded his
lines for future events and seasons are
donald was unable to keep a secret and
so far he's been great at keeping
secrets
will season eight bring back the
foundation and will we finally know what
the heck is geno and the sisters
please fortnight we need answers
theory five is about the seven realities
a quick mention to an original theory
from back in chapter one and i think it
kind of holds up today what do you think
when you hear the seven seven
individuals right this theory is based
around seven realities making each
member of the seven the same person from
a different variation of the world if
you've watched the loki tv show you'll
understand this further each reality is
slightly different which branch off from
a singular timeline the anomalies are
then hunted down and eliminated to
preserve a singularity that word again
what would happen if all seven versions
of the same person met up across those
seven realities i don't think it'll
happen but we were hella smart back then
in chapter one ggs on this theory
theory six darkness returns
kevin the cube has been at the forefront
of our thoughts since his days when he
showed us the multiverse during the live
event this season not only did we see
kevin but we saw his location on the
current map it's just by graeme the
gnome how fitting kevin has been
immortalized at steamy stacks but it
does now appear the real thing is
returning soon the cube randomly
appeared in chapter one and did its own
thing leaving runes everywhere before
making a lake bouncy the cube was
naturally drawn to the zero point kinda
like a yin and yang situation the light
being the zero point and the darkness
being the cube if the aliens are
planning to bring it back they should
know about the darkness it harnesses the
dark variations of characters like the
bright bomber all came about due to the
cube and approaching it lets us see our
dark selves now we know about snapshots
and multiple versions of the same
characters the return of the cube could
be disastrous to the island it also
could be weaponized the cube could be
the weapon the iowa looking for to sway
the battle in their favor lots of
options here season 8 will be running
over the halloween period so what a
perfect time to bring back the darkness
the horror and the cube whichever option
epic take i think we are in for a great
season i'm hoping singularity is the
last reality's leader and she'll return
to the story harnessing the cube's dark
energy which option is your favorite
i'll be snooping in the comments to find
out i'm adam you're awesome and so are
these people who use code adamaru thank
you so much really appreciate you thanks
for supporting me i'll be back soon see
ya
[Music]
bye